[Music]
no one can teach the european union
lessons about democracy we are
fighting the fire the eu
will succeed this year didn't start well
for the european commission
its rollout of the covid19 vaccine has
been widely slammed as too little
and too late but now it's decided to
invest millions into researching new
covet variants
and to try and get some better headlines
my guest this week from brussels is the
greek commissioner margueritas sheenas
will the new initiative be enough to
silence the criticism of the commission
and the charges of incompetence
[Music]
zone thank you for having me you're
pouring tens of millions of euros into
research
on new covet variants tell me this isn't
just a
elaborate pr exercise to boost your
flagging image at the commission
no it is not it is the response to a
genuine
worry that we have both here in brussels
and in the capitals
of our union because the mutations
are happening and these mutants are
practically
everywhere so we need now to
parallel to our vaccines program we need
to develop this capacity to anticipate
to adapt and facilitate the work
uh to be able to cope with all these
potential threats risk to the variants
yeah but there's a lot of work going on
in this field at the moment anyway the
world health organization said in
january that it was coordinating
a massive amount of research on the same
subject and drug companies are of course
working
on second generation vaccines to take
account of these
new strains so what are you bringing to
the table that's going to be new
we're bringing to the table uh
speed authorization procedures through
our
european medicines agency that would
allow these companies
not to resubmit from scratch but being
able to update
uh the the files on the on the basis of
which they have already
their vaccines authorized in the
european market we're bringing money
because for sequencing testing
and clinical trials at a certain scale
we need eu funding and more more than
anybody else
we need pressure pressure to everybody
involved to anticipate
events and prepare uh which hasn't been
your strong point so far has it i mean
the issue isn't money we know you've got
plenty of money
frankly the issue given the painfully
slow rollout of existing vaccines
is whether you're competent as a
commission to manage all these projects
are you
well i think the story has not been told
of the european vaccination strategy
the success of our plan will have to be
assessed
not at the beginning of the process but
at the end of it
we have pre-purchased 2.3 billion
doses of vaccines for all europeans
we have bought the 25
of the global supply we have already
dispatched
30 million doses in europe and we have
already vaccinated 22 million europeans
this is not a lack of success
this is success in the making oh mr mr
last week the commission president let's
face it was forced into a humiliating
admission
that the eu was as she put it not where
it wanted to be
in combating the virus this after
hailing the roll out as a great european
success story
but it hasn't been has it fact is you
were late in granting vaccine
authorizations
too optimistic about the production of
the vaccine too naive in believing
that all the doses would arrive on time
you were three months behind the uk
in ordering some of these vaccines you
admitted all this
this was all admitted but there was no
apology
why why was there no apology this is the
european union
in the european union politicians do not
authorize vaccines
they don't apologize either do they
independent regulatory
agencies to do that and i think that the
process we are not in the course of
speed this is not a sprint it's a
marathon
now as to the question of apology that
i leave the humiliating part to you to
to describe
but this was something the president
stated the obvious
that these companies with whom we had
contractual
uh relations and they assumed
contractual obligations
were not ready at the beginning of these
contracts
to put the capacity that the contracts
would have required
and they are sorting these delays out as
we speak
so the apology was an apology at the
moment
of the start of the contracts i'm
telling you again the eu
will succeed in our vaccination strategy
the fact is mr sheena's that people will
have died in europe waiting for you to
take decisions and get them the vaccines
that could have saved their life
someone should take responsibility for
that and resign
or is there no accountability in this
commission of yours
we are fully accountable to the european
parliament
to which uh we which we invested us in a
vote
a year ago and the european parliament
is fully
in line as are all governments of our
member states in making this
european program vaccination a success
i leave it to your imagination what
would have happened
if instead of a european strategy member
states would have
gone it individually fighting each other
over vaccines
the big member states would have swapped
the market
the smaller member states would have
never had access to the vaccines
so we are making this work for everyone
and it's working believe me
well you say this but this week the
senior liberal mep
and former belgian prime minister geva
hofstadt
accused uh ursula fonder lion of
prolonging drastically the covid
pandemic on mainland europe
at a huge cost to lives and the economy
he called the management of the
pandemica fiasco and said after two
months
the rollout of vaccines is dramatically
low
in europe so you're painting a very
different picture
from the one that members of the
european parliament are seeing
you're in trouble if figures like mr
farhofstadt
are turning against you in this way
you are quoting one of the 751 members
of the europe i can encourage others if
you like
i think no but you should quote a
majority to make the point
that the european parliament is against
the commission or a vaccine strategy you
know
in brussels there is what i call the
intellectual
appeal of pessimism somehow to be trendy
to be modern to make headlines you have
to be a pessimist
in the brussels bubble well i do not
believe in in this school of thought i'm
an
optimist and i repeat what i told you
earlier
this european strategy is working and at
the end
of the process you will see that will be
one of the most remarkable european
success
ever well that's what you say but key
figures are losing patience with you in
germany for instance the chief minister
of bavaria
marcus zurder accused the commission of
lacking the necessary sense of urgency
and following the typical normal
bureaucratic eu procedure he's right
isn't he people have a right to expect
better from you don't they
of course people have right to expect
better but i would also distance myself
from comments um coming from
a country like germany where the
election is already underway
and where many key players are uh
jogging for position ahead of the
elections and they always find very
convenient to
uh target brussels on basically
everything you know
you find it convenient to give me a
success story which hasn't yet happened
um because you're under political
pressure at the moment you're under huge
political pressure
because of the role of vaccines you know
and and for the history
of of failure dealing with this pandemic
i mean last year
there were admissions from ursula
vanderlaan that the
fundamental purpose of the eu which was
unified decision making has been sorely
lacking she said
at the time when europe really needed to
be there for each other
too many initially looked out for
themselves when europe needed an
all-for-one spirit
too many initially gaven only for me
response
the commission is the european union's
executive
if you can't unite this union isn't it
time to hand over to some people who can
i would agree with you that the
beginning in the beginning of the
pandemic
our member states last march reacted a
bit like
individuals individuals stormed the
supermarkets and bought
toilet paper and pasta hoping that they
will survive the pandemic
member states closed borders they
produced export bans they tried to
compete against each other but that
only lasted three to four weeks after
really members are still closing borders
germany closed this borders last week
its southern borders
causing traffic jams back into italy
ignoring
ignoring the justice commissioner who's
warned that it could lead to
um supply chains being disrupted
this now concerns two member states at
the time it were all member states
the the point i was trying to make
before you interrupted me
is precisely that we given the
interdependence of our single market
the integration of our supply chains we
can do
things together only we can do things
better only if we do them together
and this is happening as we speak and
again let me tell you that from borders
to public procurement to
pulling money for research to pre
buying vaccines all this is part of a
common european response which is
working
well you say it's working and i've
quoted you people who don't think it is
working
how do we know for instance that there
won't be a repeat of the january 30th
fiasco where your commission panicked
about the shortage of vaccines and
threatened to trigger a clause in the
northern ireland protocol that would
have blocked the vaccines from
reaching northern ireland the decision
was reversed
after two days and an international
outcry you're not telling me that that
was part of your success story are you
the best the the measure was not uh uh
related to northern ireland or article
16 protocol the measure which was a
valid one
was a scheme for an export authorization
procedure
that would allow the commission to know
what's happening
with uh vaccines produced in the
european market
right it would have impacted northern
ireland and it would have taught
there was a negative impact on the on
the
northern irish border which was uh uh
remedied i would say instantly uh on the
same day
and for which president vanderline
herself admitted that this was
an administrative mistake that happened
against a very broader measure which we
needed and we still need by the time to
know
who exports where vaccines
import produced in europe under
contractual obligations with europe
you said it was an administrative
mistake whose fault was that
well sometimes you know when you have to
go into
ultrasonic fast procedures because when
you
put in place an export authorization
scheme
you don't have the time a week or ten
days to organize things you have to do
it in few hours no but i asked you so
who's
whose fault it was who's gonna who's
gonna take responsibility for this the
president
herself took responsibility publicly
albeit orbee at the european parliament
twice last week
she said that she assumes personal
responsibility for the administrative
mistake
that happened on that day and which was
remedied rectified
two hours later so how do we know it's
not going to happen again
one of these administrative mistakes i
mean this this caused an enormous
amount of diplomatic backlash for you
didn't it the irish government wasn't
informed in advance nor the british
government
nor the northern ireland assembly
ireland's own ambassador called it a
very
serious mistake how do we know you're
not going to do it again
because what lessons have you learned
from that well
let me repeat that when the commission
takes
market related measures on export
authorizations we have to go
very very fast otherwise these measures
will be uh violated by events on the
ground so these decisions have been
taken
on in an afternoon and i try to explain
to you that these were decisions that
were valid
because we need this market or export
export authorization systems to know
how the vaccines are being exported and
to whom from europe
the fact that the mistake had happened
which was corrected
immediately does not mean anything
especially when the president of the
commission herself took it on herself
and publicly in front of the european
parliament assured me peace that this
will not happen again
you say it doesn't mean anything but
it's max of chaos right at the heart of
your commission doesn't it crossed wise
panicky decisions no thought for
consequences no fam
hand in control you proud of all this
look i can spend also too much time
using adjectives but i belong to a
political school of thought
that i'm not more interested in nouns
and in verbs i i don't think that you
know
value judgments in the comfort of a
tudor studio
can sort out a very complicated
situation we are
fighting a fire in a once in a
generation
threat to humanity into europe and we
will do
everything that it takes to get it right
and we are getting it right
so i prefer to be positive to be
optimistic
and look with confidence in the future
it's not just with the pandemic that
we've seen missteps is it
um we saw them the other day when your
foreign policy chief
joseph burrell visited moscow
many mps mep said he allowed himself to
be
totally humiliated and achieved
absolutely nothing
last week 81 uh members of the european
parliament called on the commission
president
to fire him should he be fired do you
think
again you are quoting a relatively small
number of meps
the european parliament has 751
uh members and the majority for the
parliament to take a stance
is half plus one that wasn't my question
i asked you whether i'm answering your
question now
before the high representative george
borrel
visited moscow do you know do you happen
to know
how many uh ministers or foreign affairs
from our member states had already
visited moscow
the answer is well that's but that's
neither here nor there
several countries poland and the baltic
states told him not to go
why why were there warnings not listened
to first of all
he went on the basis of an agreement by
the ministers of foreign affairs
council to go two we were surprised to
see
that no one bothered to criticize the 19
ministers who went to moscow before him
but everyone rushed to attack again uh
brussels
scapegoating brussels and and and
blaming everything on brussels it's
again very convenient very trendy it it
makes you popular it produces headlines
but it doesn't sort out the problems we
are in the business
of sorting out problems well you didn't
sort out any problems and he didn't sort
out any problems because he went with no
fixed agenda
didn't he engagement sessions
simple engagement sessions at foreign
minister level that's what
diplomats are supposed to do prepare
high level meetings to the smallest
detail
and find something the ministers can
agree on burrell thought he knew better
and he didn't did he
let's see about that let's see how the
uh
the noise around this visit uh
materializes in terms of policy
i'm not sure that everything has to be
judged on the basis of what happened in
a press conference
there were meetings before the press
conference and after the press
conference
and the foreign affairs ministers of the
european union are meeting
next week to assess globally the
situation
and move accordingly in a collective
manner
so the story has not yet been told of
this visit
well it's going to be interesting to see
how you move in a coordinated manner
because
half the problem is that the eu seems
incapable of unified action when it
comes to
russia you couldn't even issue a
collective statement after the poisoning
of the opposition leader alexey navalny
because it was vetoed by the hungarian
leader victor orban
so you're one more example aren't you of
a disunited multilateral body that can't
agree on
clear objectives sorry to break the news
that the european union does not have
the
capacity to decide on foreign policy on
the basis of qualified majority
foreign policy is still probably the
only one
together with taxation the only policy
where
unanimity applies and unanimity
allows everyone to stop everybody else
so of course we can self-flagellate
and regret and lament that the founding
fathers and
the governments fail to break this last
taboo of european integration
introducing majority voting and foreign
policy but that's the situation so
you are describing a situation which is
given
and on the basis of which we try to do
as much
and as best as we can with a foreign
policy chief then the problem is you
have a foreign policy chief but you
don't have a unified foreign policy
well what's the point of the job let me
remind you that we all
already have sanctions against russia on
the started book
we are already renewing periodically
sanctions that have been agreed
unanimously and we do have many other
instruments
and decisions that have been agreed
unanimously but of course
we do not have a qualified majority that
would have allowed us to
to move differently this is the
situation and we can spend
time lamenting it or regretting it but i
don't think we can change it
at this stage mr margaritas china has
also
benefited from the eu's lack of a
consistent foreign policy hasn't it you
you trumpet human rights as a central
value to the european union
but you threw those considerations to
the wind when you signed an investment
deal
with beijing last month didn't you the
the only assurance from china
about human rights was a a meaningless
and totally unenforceable commitment
to make sustained and continuous efforts
to ratify
intervention international conventions
on forced labor
in other words they do their best no
time scale maybe ten years maybe a
hundred
who knows but why don't you admit it you
got nothing from the chinese did you
nothing okay again leaving the
adjectives
uh aside nothing is a noun
on the substance of this of your
question uh
with this agreement uh the european
union
obtained a level of protection of
investment by european companies in
china
that our american partners our friends
already have so this was not an
apocalyptic
new thing it was aligning european
interest to a level of protection
that other western powers already enjoy
with china so i i think it was a
necessary agreement
a welcome agreement and an agreement
that creates more jobs and more
certainty for our companies and for the
economy
and i will also take issue with your
assertion
that this was done at the back of human
rights
precisely as part of this agreement
there are concrete
references to the need to ratify the ilo
agreements
on child labor there are relevant
considerations of the situation in
xin yang the european union will
continue to engage with china in a
principled
and at the same time pragmatic way you
didn't
impress the european parliament did you
there was scathing condemnation and a
resolution which was unanimously passed
which said that by rushing to reach this
agreement while not taking
concrete action against ongoing grave
human rights violations in
hong kong xinjiang province and tibet
the eu risks
undermining its credibility as a global
human rights actor the chair of the
parliament's delegation for relations
with china
reinhardt boutique said it's ridiculous
for the eu to try selling that
as a success you didn't you didn't
convince them
we no one can teach the european union
lessons about democracy and respect of
human rights
we are the uh world's epicenter of
democracy and good governance we're a
great
look at poland can you honestly say that
can you honestly say that
let me first let me first discuss hong
kong and then i'm happy to go to
poland and hungary on hong kong we are
gravely concerned
the situation there is against uh
everything that we stand for
uh we have repeatedly expressed both of
the commission
at the council of foreign affairs
ministers our
uh position and the situation against
the democracy pro-democracy fighters
and activists and candidates and these
concerns
have been put to president xi by
the european leaders in their meeting of
the 30th of december
just just words mr margaritis you had
leverage real
leverage with this financial agreement
with this trade deal
with china and you didn't use that
leverage
we used it to the best possible
outcome at a level comparable to what
our
american friends did when dealing with
china
so this was not something that
failed our standards we lived up to our
standards the the references to
ilo resolutions child labor situation
xin yang are clearly established let's
just look
briefly at your claim that the european
union is the most advanced model of
democracy in society in the modern world
seems like a classic eu exaggeration
when you look at
poland and hungary according to human
rights organizations
human rights watch for instance says 10
million eu citizens in hungary are
effectively
living under authoritarian rule in
poland the government
is accused by the eu itself of violating
the union's laws
undermining judicial independence in
bulgaria
torture is rife along with massive
corruption at all levels
of government how does that fit into the
most advanced
model of democracy in society in the
modern world
the rule of law and the respect for the
rule of law democracy
and fundamental rights are the jewels in
the crown
of the european union they are
non-negotiable
i do not deny that in certain parts of
our geography
the the the weight of history and
authority
authoritarianism totalitarianism still
has a resilient
presence if you like and we are now for
some years
working very very consistently
and i would say aggressively to remedy
these
pathologies in making clear that the
rule of law has to be respected by
all member states at all levels you've
been telling bulgaria that for 14 years
but instead of doing it
only by threatening the nuclear button
of article 7 of the treaty we have now
recently
introduced a new approach through a
european rule of law mechanism
that allows us on a yearly basis to scan
examine the situation in all our member
states from the point of view rule of
law
engage in dialogue upstream and instead
of correcting
making sure that we shape a situation
the way we like it
we have introduced a mechanism on
conditionality with respect to rule of
law in the next eu budget
we have very many open can't
infringements
statements we're running out of time
unfortunately we've run out of time that
this ecosystem will produce change
okay thank you very much for being on
conflict zone thank you for your time
sir thank you for having me
[Music]
you